hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie and today we're gonna work with
state and react and let me fix this
screen for you if you remember yesterday
I had some different monitors hooked up
to this laptop so I'd shifted around the
screen and so last few minutes I've just
been trying to get everything back to
normal so happy Friday
it's crazy the weeks already over I got
off to a late start today I had my
youngest son Ambrose who's 3 he's been
having trouble swallowing and been
getting things like stuck in his throat
so we went in for some testing this
morning at a hospital and he wanted me
to go so I went in with him and he did a
great job all the nurses said it he did
better than then the grown men that were
in there before him so I was proud of
that little guy so I took him out to
McDonald's afterwards so anyway enough
about me but anyway I just meant say I
got off to a really late start today
because of that
so I haven't had gotten to do that much
with the project so it's pretty much in
the same state that it was in yesterday
so most of my work has just been in
transferring data from the old database
to the new database which you know all
that is kind of behind the scenes and
nobody really sees that let me I want to
move the chat window over to my other
screen so that I can see it more easily
and I don't miss your comments and so
there was a live stream about the free
code camp YouTube channel on another
YouTube channel called engineered truth
I think that's what it was
I'm pretty sure that was the name of the
channel but anyway it I should have
grabbed the URL for you I don't have it
right now but it was a pretty cool I've
seen it with Quincy who if you're not
familiar with free cocaine Quincy is the
founder and the head of free code camp
but Quincy was talking with another
youtuber whose channel was very
successful and this other youtuber was
giving Quincy a lot of advice on how to
make the free code camp YouTube channel
better so it's pretty cool but it so if
you have your own channel and you want
some advice on on how to grow your
channel definitely check that video out
I mean a lot of the advice is not
specific to free code camp and could
definitely be applied to a lot of
different different types of channels
different content but especially if you
have a channel about about tech or
coding check that out
so that was that was really cool and of
course it was cool to see my videos on
the screen there in the live stream when
kolinsky was showing like the YouTube
dashboard behind the scenes and so
anyway that was cool I may be trying to
incorporate some new things into my
streams I'm gonna try to maybe name them
may my streams like a little bit better
so there's not gonna be any major major
changes for me but you know maybe just
some some really like you know subtle
things okay so it looks like yeah
alright so we have a decent amount of
viewers in here right now so I think
we're safe too to get started so I
figured today we'll do two Pomodoro
sessions
so those are two 25-minute periods of
code and in between those periods of
code I'll answer some questions and the
live chat so if you have any questions
feel free to put in the live chat I
won't
probably won't get to your question
immediately but I will answer it before
the stream is over
so I I'm sorry I'm distracted by
messages coming in so just for the new
people in here for those of you who are
seeing the stream a lot sorry I'm gonna
go over this again but at least once a
week I think I'm gonna try to go over
what we're doing in the stream so the
quick version for everyone who's new is
this is my daily work I'm a front-end
developer for a small University and I
work partly from home and partly in the
office I'm at home today and whatever I
need to work on for for my job is what I
stream so these streams aren't exactly
tutorials although I do my best to
explain what I'm doing and I'll answer
any questions that you have but I say
they're not tutorials because sometimes
we all go in a logical order in terms of
starting with beginner level stuff and
working away it up I just have to work
on what needs to get done so having said
that I just want everybody have the
right mindset coming in that you know
it's not a tutorial but it is a glimpse
into my work as a front-end developer I
may not be the average front-end
developer I don't really know but it may
be helpful for you all to see what kind
of work I do and most importantly how
often I mess up because I I do mess up
quite frequently if you don't believe me
ask people in the live chat I'm sure
anybody that's been watching for you
know more than a few shows to see me
mess up quite a bit but we worked
through that together so feel free to
put your opinions in as well
if you see me in doing something that
looks wrong call me out on it
all right I am very very open to
constructive criticism so yeah so don't
don't be afraid like I'm not here as the
expert really I'm I'm here is just
another web developer and just sharing
my stuff and sharing what I do all right
let's get start
and first I'm gonna make this bigger so
I'm sure that's difficult for you all to
see and that should be big enough let me
know so I have a preview open on my
other screen so if I can read the text
then usually it's good for you all to
read it and so right now let me give you
a recap if you're interested in seeing
all the code yourself or even
downloading the code for your own use or
for you to work on it check out the link
in the description for this github repo
alright so we we there's a really good
question that just popped up in the live
chat and it'll be good for me to address
this before we start state management so
the question of state management are we
doing Redux mob X so here's what we're
doing we're using component state right
so usually when you hear about state
management it's followed by with Redux
or with mob X or with whatever okay but
we're gonna use component just regular
component state why would we use that
well I I don't think we need mob X or
redux
right so those are excellent things I've
used them before I really I should say
I've used redux before I haven't used my
backs but I'm I'm aware of the
differences so I like them both and I
think they're very useful when needed
but I don't think we have the complexity
here in our use case that warrants
bringing them on so I'm gonna go through
ok well what if we don't really have to
do that much but we do need to manage
state we just need to pass state between
a few parent and children components
right how do we do that so that's what
we're going to do today we're going to
have the state live
an apparent component and then it's
gonna get passed down I think two levels
to a child component right in this case
a grandchild component I guess alright
and then we're going to change the state
that lives up here in the top component
when we click on the child component so
we're gonna have to pass around some
things so the state of open or close
gets passed down as props to our child
component but then also we're gonna need
a click handler that's gonna live in the
parent component that also gets passed
down to the child component alright so
this is not something like
groundbreaking or really new like no
one's ever done this before
in fact we've done some similar things
in our projects before this but I'd like
to walk through it with you all and I
should here we are okay so let's see
let's get rid of that I still haven't
fixed the warnings on there so apologies
for all that so here's what we have we
have a drop-down menu and then inside
here we have a secondary level right and
right now what happens is so I've opened
these up and if I click out of here and
I try to go back in they're closed
that's not a really great user
experience right because if I go to this
section like let's say I go into one of
these pages in the undergraduate section
and I realize either I've read that page
and I want to learn more or oh I'm on
the wrong page then the user ought to be
able to go directly back here and pick
up right where they left off but that's
not happening right now
okay why is that not happening well
that's
we're gonna figure out why and figure
out how to fix it right and we can see
that we've managed to get that to work
here so I can open academics I can shut
it and open it back up and it's still
open right so we have the correct
behavior that's happening here but not
down here all right so I'd say the the
first place that we ought to look then
is how are we doing this here already
and can we use that same technique for
this this other part of this menu so for
that let's go here and let's see we have
drawer item
okay yes a drawer item drawer item is
our component that and I forgot to start
my clock there we go let's start our
Pomodoro timer so drawer item is you
know this this component so these are
the drawer items so we can see in drawer
item let's see we do have this click
Handler and that is what is expanding
those those sub menus alright the the
lowest level of the menu but we don't
have any other click handlers right so
at that top level which is here this top
list item when we have an on-click and
expands the item it it calls this expand
item and it passes in this case the item
ID but where is this coming from
right so that's the click Handler and
then number two how do they how does it
know that that's supposed to be expanded
well it's from this is open props so we
need to track is open and we need to
track expand item up the component tree
and see what we're doing
so drawer item the parent component for
drawer item is drawer so let's see
what's going on in
so let's find out where we have a drawer
item and see what we're passing there
okay so here's our is open and our
expand item so it looks like this drops
drawer menus about so it's actually
props we're getting it from props here
and then we're also getting this from
props as well so our state doesn't live
in this component either we need to go
up another component so let's let's
check it out now the parent component of
drawer is a component called layout
which I don't think I have up right now
all right so let's open this up and find
layout layout touch yes we'll close this
all right so in layout let's see what we
have let's go let's go down here to
where we have drawer and you can see
we're passing down the toggle drawer or
I'm sorry the expand items and then draw
items this yeah so this is what we're we
were past passing down so you can see we
passing down from layout to drawer so
you could see drawer items in this case
it's dot about because this particular
item is about we're not gonna be hard
coding the item name so we're definitely
gonna have to come up with a different
way to do that and then the expand item
so and then we see that's what finally
gets passed down to our droid and
component so let's go back up to layout
and see where these are coming from
so let's find expand item which is a
function that lives in this component
and then let's check out state to look
at drawer items in state so
expand item accepts item ID and then
based on that ID it changes the state of
that particular item from either open or
closed or I believe it's true or false
yeah so it's true or false meaning if
it's true it's open if it's false it's
closed so the menus you know true or
open or closed okay so that's where
essentially this needs to be either
replicated or change so that it can work
in both situations what I'm gonna do
first is we're gonna replicate this
we're gonna move basically we're gonna
move this function this sub item
expander function right we're gonna move
that out of this component and into
layout and try to make the same thing
work here now if we find that maybe we
could refactor and only use one function
for both maybe we'll do that first thing
first things first let's just get it
working now at this point I do want to
ask do you think that it's necessary to
have it live all the way at that top
component for it to work like we want it
to could we just change things so that
it would work without moving it up so
I'm gonna start working on this but I do
want to know if anybody if anybody
really thinks hey there's a better way
to do this I'd rather consider a
different way now then then do all the
work
and figure out that if it's not gonna
work or we could have done in a better
way
alright so as if anybody's gonna I know
there's a delay so if anybody is gonna
throw in their opinion I'll keep
checking the live chat but while I'm
doing that let's see first thing we're
gonna take is this we're actually let's
remove this console load I don't think
we need the console log anymore
okay we're gonna move this first and
then we're gonna move this state ok now
if you'll remember we already have
drawer items in the state here so we may
have to change the name which is not
really big deal so first let's take this
take it out of here and let's add it in
now we've already renamed it from this
other component which it was based on or
this other function that was based on so
we should be okay so now that is there
but what we need to do is pass this down
as a problem so in the same way that
we've done this with expand item we're
gonna pass it down as well to drawer as
expand sub item alright so now expand
sub item will be available to the drawer
component alright so this function will
be able to call this function from the
drawer component all right so that's one
step we got to take another step after
that but first things first let's get
this state set
as well so I don't want to mess up
what's going on here with drawer items
like I said we can always refactor later
if we find that you know hey baby we
don't need separate things so I'm gonna
say drawer sub items okay now that I
think about it that naming doesn't make
the most sense but I think it's I think
it'll work
so for sub items yeah we're not gonna
put anything there yet right because
we're not hard-coding the values so
we're just gonna leave that as an empty
object and now let's modify what we have
here because we're no longer gonna be
setting the state for drawer items we
want to set it for drawer sub items and
we have to change what's here as well
drawers sub items okay so that's now
when this is called it will take drawer
sub items and it will combine whatever
was there with the new value for this
particular item so so far so good I mean
logic wise it seems like it makes sense
okay great
oh I know we need to pass down the
drawer sub-items thought I was
forgetting something
so let's pass down we'll just copy this
so we can change it
sub-items
okay draw some items let's save that and
now let's go down to drawer so remember
we now have drawer sub items and expand
sub item that were we're gonna have
access to and drawer J s alright so it's
gonna be a little bit different here so
let's take this is open am I gonna do
this I was hoping to find a way to do
this oh yeah here we go so we have four
drawer items in here which it's it's a
little silly we should really just map
over these but we never got around to
refactoring that so did I not get all of
them no all right so I'm sure Chinese
multiple cursors to do all this in one
go instead of copy and pasting yeah okay
so I'm gonna have a new line here and
we're gonna call this expand sub item
and we're going to
this drops item okay so essentially
we're just passing that function down
another level we're not doing anything
with it we're just passing it on and
then we need want to change one more
thing and let's see this is open and
actually how did I pass this on Joris
Ivens okay so I'm going to let's see
let's take this is open and so is sub
open okay once again the naming could
probably use a little work here but what
we're gonna pass down is this props
items let's make sure got everything
alright looks like it okay so once again
all we're doing here is just passing
down everything from layout through
drawer to drawer item we've done nothing
to change it okay now here's what we
need to do a little bit of more work so
we don't need state now in this
component
because our state now lives in layout
well what we do have are a few more
props so let's add them here so that we
don't have to write this props within
our component so we have is sub open and
we also have expand sub item let me
check my timer alright great ten minutes
I feel I think we're going good on time
because I haven't messed anything up yet
like I'm doing a good job today okay so
now we we need to use these in the
proper place so what we're gonna do
let's just grab this so that we can just
kind of copy exactly what's going on
here so let's go into our sub menu items
and within there we're mapping over the
items and if a particular item has
another menu within it another sub menu
then we're rendering this particular
version of it and we need this on click
whoops not that one wrong one trying to
find the right on click
expand sub-item there we are okay so
we're gonna expand the sub-item
we don't need this all right so before
we were calling this directly now we
don't need it we have it work yeah so
expand sub-item and then we're passing
it the item text so that that's gonna be
like the item ID that we saw in in the
function when we moved it into layouts
and then we need to make sure we're
grabbing the right items yes so we no
longer can get drawer items we need to
get drawer sub items
is that okay
so we called it I'm pretty sure we did
to sign it
well let's get rid of this as well so
that doesn't live in state what did we
call him again oh you know what we just
said is sub open
all right I think all right this is the
first mess up I think I forgot I forgot
something yeah so what we're doing let
me climb back up here to the top so we
were getting some data where we're
getting the data from the data was
coming into the floor wasn't it
well there we are okay so here's our
data so let me make sure we're gonna you
have the data and we need okay I think
we're fine I think I just
[Music]
yes okay yes let's go is sub open hmm
yeah is sub open I don't all right
that's what we need
sorry I was freaking out for a second
because I was like wait a second like
how are we getting our data in here and
that was fine
we didn't everything's all right so
instead of draw right UM's again we need
is sub open we are just double-checking
here making sure we have everything and
now this should not affect anything down
here because this is only for items that
don't have a sub menu okay all right
well let's save it and best way to
figure out if we mess it up is just to
check it out so if the page renders
that's a good sign and it looks like it
does I'm gonna give it our refresh just
to be sure
interesting okay so we got a flash of an
error I don't know what that was for
also let me check my time all right
three minutes
in about three minutes I'm gonna go to
the live chat and answer some questions
okay so that was a good sign
I don't know what I mean other than that
weird air that flashed up if it does it
again then we'll look at it otherwise I
think we'll be alright so let's check
out this menu alright so that part still
works wonderful we didn't mess with it
so as to be expected let's see if this
click works oh that works let's see if
it works for two different ones
wonderful alright now let's shut the
drawer and open it again nice it works
see and it works for two of them nice I
do want to test this out if I close
academics and then open it nice it's
still open I want to close this shut it
open it nice alright our state is like
super persistent now this is the
behavior that we wanted excellent
excellent
okay so does anyone know I want to ask a
question before I explain why I think
this happened why like seeing y'all saw
when we took the code we didn't really
change it other than some names all we
did was take the same function in the
same state and then move it up two
components and now the behavior is
different why is the behavior different
why before did those sub menus
automatically get shut when we closed
the side drawer and open it back up and
why now are they staying open why is the
state persisting now when it didn't
before so let me let me know what you
all think
and my timers got to be up by now just
about okay I'm just gonna go to the
short break right now since I'm not
really gonna get anything done in a
minute
I'm scroll up to the top of the chat and
I'm gonna go down through and get to as
many questions as I can and I'll give
you all time to answer why you think the
state didn't persist and now it does
persist it's you see a lot of what are
you saying hi grandpa
fat voices good evening everyone I don't
know that I've seen that name in here so
welcome welcome
it's especially welcome to all the
newcomers in here let's see Aniki says
sorry I missed yesterday's dream about
the infinite scrolling seeing how we did
it in JAF intersection observers awesome
oh you know what Nikki I didn't I
totally forgot about it in JSA yeah I'm
gonna check that out because we we
didn't fully implement it so yeah I will
check that out because that's probably a
better way than what I was thinking
Michael says you should add backup
singers to your stream backup singers
make everything better
alright cool baby you know what my
wife's always singing all the time so
maybe she'll want to be a backup singer
now King King Dario said heresy just
messing around I assume that was in
response when I said we're just gonna
use component state so yeah and for
those of you who aren't familiar with
reacts that much they're you you do see
like I mean it I've seen it shipped back
and forth but you would you know at one
point people were saying like never use
component state you always want to use
Redux right and that was I think like
overboard they use too much to the one
way I think it's more balanced now I do
see people saying and have been for a
little while saying like no component
state is the right way to do it if it's
not a too complex so anyway yeah it's
it's perfectly acceptable to use super
28 says what are you using here for
theming material you I see hey Phoenix
is here how's it going Oh King Dora says
there's also a library called unstated
which looks good this is but I like to
use mob X personally cool yeah I've been
interested in mob X I just haven't
really had a project to use it on and to
learn it I haven't heard of unstated and
off to check that out alright so see
some of the answers about when I was
asking like how should we do this where
should the state live so it looks like
most of you most of you agreed that the
states should probably live in and lay
out a noble and savage says hubba-hubba
liking your new office yeah like
literally
I am just in my basement in a corner of
the laundry room
I have a recliner and then I just have a
a table with some monitors on it I have
a laptop on my lap and I hung up like
it's not even a curtain it's a
tablecloth I hung a tablecloth from the
rafters and just to give me some sort of
background so so y'all can't don't see
like my family walking around back there
so that's my office for now it works the
recliner is comfy
Phoenix is I'm about to start with react
in a few days I'm overwhelmed by the
examples that are available I don't know
where to start Twitter clone medium
clone shopping app website what you know
what I would say if you're looking for
projects to start with check out the
free code camp projects and just do it
in react so look at the very first most
basic one you do and try to implement
that and react even if reacts probably
overkill for it but the point is just to
learn react and start out slow since I
think what's the first one is it
the first project is I thank the tribute
page tell me that's I've heard of people
doing that going through free code camp
projects and doing them with react so I
would try that
okay so I did not get all the way
through all the questions right now
oh but actually you know what let me
just go through the questions because I
mean really we actually got it to work
it's just insane
let me go through some more of these
questions and then I want to see if
anybody answered that last question I
asked and and we're gonna go over that
so I did get through most of them so
there's not that much left
okay so John Kane recommends react 16
the complete guide which was $10 on
udemy so check that out I've never
checked it out so that's not really an
endorsement I'm just you know but John
John Kane thinks it's good Johnson John
Hanson says Jesse kindly suggested that
I give react to try I had barely gone
from a simple understanding of jQuery to
JavaScript at the time now I have a
fairly good grasp
go for it awesome John I'm I'm glad to
hear that
that you're getting a good grasp and
that's really cool that that you
consider me to be the one that was kind
of got you into that so really cool
nikki says following along with her
tutorial helped me andrew medes and max
schwartz mueller's are both great ok
cool a lot of good resources thank you
Carlos says Max's course is awesome
and you're asked what Mike I'm using
actually so when I'm working from home I
just used the built-in mic for a MacBook
Pro when I'm in my office like at at my
place of work I have like a USB mic I
don't even remember the brand it was
inexpensive from Amazon I'm probably
gonna end up getting a mic for home and
maybe even a camera like an external
camera because I when I have the laptop
on my lap it tends to shift around a bit
and I don't want I don't want to give
anybody motion sickness by the the
shifting of the camera so I think it'd
be better if I had just a small tripod
and and a camera that was stationary
I bought the tripod already it came in I
got a notification from Amazon I so I
think it's sitting outside my door right
now but I haven't decided what camera to
buy and the webcams are a bit more
expensive so I want to put some thought
into which one I should get ok so Carlos
says the state persists because they
went to the parent waited yeah so going
to the parent was why it persists but
let's see so I want to see I'll explain
why I think it what I think the like
exact issue was but I want to see what
you all say first so Lee says just
manage says hi I just managed to join in
now just came back from work Jesse I
missed your past to live is because you
started early oh okay yeah sorry about
that
I've been starting at different times if
I start early then
my viewers in India and anywhere in that
time zone are those couple time zones
you know together they are better able
to watch otherwise it's too late for
them so I don't know so for right now
I'm kind of switching back and forth so
do some a little later some earlier so
sorry about that I know it's there's no
time I can stream that works for
everybody so right now I'm just
streaming it at like different times and
so sometimes you know different people
will be able to catch it live other
times you know you may just have to
catch the recording so I just I don't
really know any other way to do it
to try to be fair about it so that
everybody gets a chance to watch the
watch it live you know other than
burying the time javascript is here says
Jesse what's up nothing much just
working how you doing
and it's actually it's a really nice day
here finally you know it's it's it's
been pretty cold lately so today is like
70 degrees sunny a little breeze really
nice I mean I'm in a basement with
coding but it's so cool that it's nice
Frankie says the recliner looks
comfortable it's actually it's
comfortable but it is it's really old I
got this recliner from my grandfather
who had used it for a while and decided
he's ready to get a new one
so then I got this recliner when I was
in I still in high school I think I may
have still been in high school I'm 32
years old now so I was a teenager I
think when I got this recliner and I had
the same setup at my parents house in my
bedroom
where I had a recliner and multiple
monitors I used them back in the day to
play video games not coding and I just
after I got married I took the recliner
with me and just have replicated this
setup everywhere that I've lived every
time I moved I just take it so it's
actually like it's pretty ripped up it's
still comfortable but I mean it's I'm
sure it's not nearly as comfortable it
was what it was new but it's not
suitable to be in my living room but
it's okay to be in my basement
javascript or says don't make jquery and
react that idea yeah for sure it makes
things difficult if you for some reason
half the mix jquery and react checkout
project one on the playlist for live
coding with jesse because we did that
and we made it work
I'd love to change it so that we don't
need jQuery but I go at some point in
that series that project one I go
through and explain like why you
shouldn't do it like this and then I
explain if you have to do it anyway
here's how we do it and we we make it
work and that that sites actually still
live and in doing well so it can be done
it's not the best way to do it so so
don't don't do it if you can avoid it
but sometimes it's you can't really
avoid it
JavaScript er says where do you work I
work at Franciscan University of
Steubenville it's a small Catholic
College in like eastern Ohio so I don't
know how familiar you all are with
United States geography but there's a
point where the state West Virginia so
the northernmost part of West Virginia
meets with Eastern Ohio and western
Pennsylvania and right where those meet
together
well student bills like pretty much
right there so Steubenville is very
close to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania so if
you know where Pittsburgh is on a map
just move a little bit west of there and
as soon as you cross the border into
from west region from Pennsylvania into
West Virginia and then into Iowa that's
where student of us but anyway it's a
small school I think we only have two
thousand students and I'm a front-end of
for their but it's it's nice I it's only
about ten minutes from where I live it's
it's right next to where I grew up I
grew up in West Virginia right across
the Ohio River from where I live now and
so my kids get to be around their
cousins and their grandparents all the
time my wife's family is actually from
student my wife grew up in student oh so
so I really wanted my kids to grow up
around all their family so that's why we
we end up here so it works well works
out well that I can I can work here be
able to provide for my family
I know a lot of a lot of people that
grew up in this area had to move away
because it's not really economically
doing well but thankful that I was able
to stay here let's see I lost my place
I'm trying to scroll up and find life
hey Nikki says on the state not
persisting before you put state higher
did the component get unmounted that
would explain it
yes I believe we have a winner there so
my thought was so after we implemented
this I don't know it was a couple days
ago or something I noticed that behavior
and I thought oh that's no good like we
can't have that behavior and and I've
started thinking about it and that's
what I thought is Oh like what's
happening is right like when state lived
at this level right at this level like
it would save the state here but then
once this drawer was hidden like that
was hid component unmount state is reset
and then when we open it again it starts
from all over again
so the reason why that didn't happen
with these was because the state for
these things
live way up at layout and layout
encompasses all of this the whole
page so in layout we have this app bar
the footer and the side drawer and
layout doesn't unmount layout stays as
is and then this content here changes so
if we want any state to persist it needs
to be in layout right so that's what I
thought
oh okay if we just move it up to layout
if we move the state up to layout then
it will persist because it'll never
unmount so you can see now like the
benefit one of the benefits of using
something like Redux where the state
would actually be stored somewhere else
that is completely unaffected by
components mounting and unmounting right
if if you didn't easily have access to a
top level component where you could
store that state let's say your
component was like 8 levels deep you
don't want to pass that state all the
way down right that's that would be
ridiculous then something like Redux
would be super helpful because the
component the child component would
immediately have access then to your
Redux store where your state would would
live in this case since we're only
talking about two levels it was fun
all right it makes sense would we have a
little bit you know less code in our
components if we went with Redux a
little bit less but then having all that
extra Redux stuff there doesn't really
make sense so if we were doing this kind
of thing everywhere all over the place
passing it down you know even further
yeah then it would make sense and
actually with the latest versions of
Apollo which is what we're using to get
our graph QL data you can also do
similar things like that like to save
your state in a store so we probably
wouldn't even use Redux we would use the
Apollo version of that all right so does
that make sense everyone
good job Nikki and who else someone else
said so Carlos was on on the right track
as well and so a good job for catching
on to that I feel like I'm teaching a
class when I was asking questions but I
just I don't know what did give you all
a chance to like say it first instead of
me just talking about it anyway so
that's the reason if anybody needs next
like a better explanation of that let me
know I'll try to do a better job John
Cain says I recommend the Razr Keough
webcam a hundred bucks on Amazon okay
cool let me you know let me open that up
right now so I don't forget what it is
on and then on another screen all right
so I will check that out after the
stream I'm glad you mentioned that
because I hadn't heard of that before it
at Amazon like all the webcams that come
up or like logitech webcam
I'm skipping through a bit just trying
to find some questions
all right so several several of you are
saying where you're from so we have
India Switzerland awesome Virginia
so Blacksburg Virginia very cool so
you're only one well I guess two states
over for me since I'm not in West
Virginia anymore
Oh JavaScript Oh says you're like half a
state away from me awesome Frankie says
can you view the mountains from your
region in West Virginia where I'm at
well I mean where I grew up which is
just across the river from where I'm at
right now
it's it's like hills there are big Hills
right there not really like mountainous
so I would have to drive a little bit
further into West Virginia to really get
into with the Appalachian Mountains yeah
so it's not it's not that far but it's a
little bit of a drive so I'm kind of in
the foothills of of the mountains so
that's definitely definitely some steep
winding roads around here but not
exactly mountains but the state West
Virginia as a state is really beautiful
and actually like Virginia is - like
that whole region like driving through
there is just I mean there's some really
cool if you're into like outdoor stuff
like I don't know like whitewater
rafting camping hiking stuff like that I
mean you can't be West Virginia I mean
it's like so much of the the state
doesn't have a high population so so
much the state is just forests and
mountains and lakes and rivers and stuff
it's just like untouched wilderness
basically so it's really it's kind of
cool and it's still pretty close to a
lot of major cities and airports and
things so you know you get kind of like
the best of both worlds that you have
the wilderness generally like really low
property values low taxes but if you
really want to do enjoy like city life
it's not that far away anyway I'm not
getting paid by the tourism department
of any state to say that that's my
honest opinion
Gabriel's saying hi from Sao Paulo
Brazil awesome
said well thanks for watching
sunny asked what language this is
JavaScript Oh Nicki already answered I
should have known somebody would have
answered let's see
Renato asked what my opinion is on mob X
I from what I've seen of mob X I really
like it
it honestly seems like a slightly less
complex version of Redux so I'm not
saying they're the same thing right so
they both solve like the same problem
but in in slightly different ways so I
would say I ended up learning Redux
first because it was a part of the
Udacity nano degree if I had just
decided to learn on my own I probably
would have learned mob X first because
it seems like mob X is a little bit
easier to deal with so unfortunately I
haven't worked with it directly myself
so I don't really want to say too much
more about it you know because it I
don't know that I could give a really
good good explanation or information but
if you're interested in using mob X and
you're trying to decide between Redux
and mob X I would if it were me I'd
probably go with mob X I try to learn
that first although I mean me right now
since I already know Redux I might go
with Redux but if I hadn't learned Redux
first I'd probably go to my bags
hopefully that made sense I felt like I
was talking to circles for a second
Nietzsche says reacts 16.3 also has the
new context api you can use for that oh
that's right that's right thank you for
bringing that up neatly I can't believe
I forgot yeah so the latest versions of
react
I have another way to handle state which
I need to learn more about that and
maybe start using that Carlos's teach us
Jesse we want to learn and love your
videos that's awesome thanks for saying
that
hi Frankie says thanks you Tech sorry if
I'm mispronouncing that name I think
it's you Tech says hi and greetings from
Poland all right awesome
I have my wife my wife's family and my
family both have ancestors from Poland
so I've never been there but part of my
family tree originated in Poland so that
that's cool Frankie says I'm the girl
who wants to go off grid so I agree
totally cool that was what I was talking
about like the you know the mountains
and stuff yeah it's um it's cool at one
time I was really into like the whole
like homesteading thing like raise your
own you know animals and have a garden
and all kind of stuff like that um so
right now I actually live outside of
like city limits so it's like at one
time I did raise animals and do the
whole like I wasn't completely off the
grid but that was I was like working my
way up to it and then it I don't know it
got it got difficult with trying to work
full-time and raise kids have four kids
and things it was just I kind of just
let it go and we I still have a garden
and every you know stuff like that
but I don't raise any animals anymore
all right let's see I'm gonna scroll
down I my live chat window is messed up
no I can't my live chat window got
messed up and so I can't read anything
let me restore it over here please work
yes all right I got it back all right
sorry about that
Renate says thanks for the answer since
yeah Malbec seems much simpler to
understand at first yeah that was I mean
that was my impression
Youssou says greetings from Indonesia
awesome
hi Frankie says right I completely
comprehend off-grid alright cool
well that's the end of that's a guide to
the bottom of the the chat the live chat
and I know I said at the beginning I was
gonna do two Pomodoro sessions but
amazingly I somehow managed to do what I
wanted to do without messing up too
badly and finished it in one Pomodoro
session which that is very very rare i
I've done for sure over a hundred live
streams and it I would imagine there may
be less than ten live streams where we
accomplished everything we wanted to
like in a shorter amount of time so
today was a great day a great way to end
the week and thank you all so much for
watching and for all your your advice in
the live chat and and your help it was
it was fun it was really fun stream
today so I think I'll be back Monday
yeah what's going on Monday I should be
able to stream on Monday I'll be in the
office then not sure what we'll be doing
then but probably most likely working on
this same project and it's not sure
exactly what we'll do so and there were
a lot of new people in the stream today
so I want to say again welcome thank you
so much for watching hopefully you can
all come back again for for another
stream and yeah so I hope everyone has a
really really awesome weekend
so until until Monday I guess have have
a great weekend
see ya later